Speaker 1: One of the hallmarks of pseudo
intellectualism is to say things that are
really simple or overtly counterintuitive
and to pretend that they're profound or that
they give some unique insight, something no
one else is willing to say, maybe when in
reality they're just wrong.
Now, you might be saying, David, what are
you talking about?
I have an example for you right here.
There is a guy who some might be familiar
with.
His name is Ty Smith.
He's a conservative black father who's being
popularized by right wing media as a conservative
black father who is willing to tell the truth
about race related issues.
And the truth is he sees it is us, isn't racist,
hasn't been racist.
And now he even says slavery wasn't racist
in the United States.
Let's just get right into it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, because they're very invested
in this whole idea that the nation was founded
on the idea of systemic racism that is built
into every single institution in America,
even the military.
Right.
Folks are worried that this is something that
they need to address within the military.
And we just did a story about how the Navy
is underprepared right now, but they're spending
a heck of a lot of time on this.
What do you think about that
Speaker 3: is absolutely absurd, because nobody
really wants to get the real history of integrating.
America was not founded on racism.
Don't get me wrong, there was slavery going
on.
But slavery itself was not initially a racist
thing.
It never slavery
Speaker 1: itself was not initially a racist
thing.
And right wingers watching Fox, all of a sudden
this guy appears and they say, whoa, hold
on a second, it's Fox.
So I trusted implicitly and here's a black
guy saying not only was this nation not racist
in its in its foundation, but even slavery
wasn't racist.
And this guy is black.
So now I'm.
Absolved of having to actually deal with any
racial inequity or whatever.
I don't have to feel guilty about anything
as if that's actually the point.
Right.
This is crazy.
This is.
Let's listen to a little bit more.
Speaker 3: Was about race initially.
So to sit there and take it like America was
founded on racism is a complete lie.
Yeah, there was slavery going on, but slavery
was going on in all the world.
It never was a race thing.
So why are we making it a race thing now?
Speaker 1: So there's a bunch of stuff there
that we can address.
All right.
The one of the things he says is sort of a
red herring right now.
It is true that there were African slaves
in places other than the United States.
He says slavery was going on all over the
world.
It's true.
Only about four to six percent of African
slaves that were taken from Africa came to
the United States.
The other ninety four to ninety six percent
went to other places.
Sometimes even within Africa, they were enslaved.
That doesn't change whether slavery in the
United States was racist.
I hope that you realize that that's a complete
and total red herring.
Now, sometimes what you will hear is slavery
in the US wasn't racist because there were
Irish people also enslaved in colonial America
early on.
That's also not true.
Large numbers of indentured servants did come
to the United States from Ireland and in fact,
went to numerous British colonies, including
those in North America.
They they chose to do it.
The conditions were absolutely terrible.
Indentured servitude has elements of slavery,
including that you're bound to the whoever
you're working for for a period of time.
But it's not actually slavery.
It's terrible.
But indentured servitude is not chattel slavery.
So that's another argument that they will
sometimes make.
And then to even say that it wasn't racist
in that I don't even know what they mean.
Do they mean it just so happened that they
were bringing people from Africa, all of whom
were black?
I don't know how you argued that that's not
racist in its in its implementation.
And if you can even look at things written
at the time about slavery, one reason that
you will find written about why why is it
African slaves that are brought to the US?
One reason is they were chosen for their dark
skin so they could work out in the sun all
day and I guess, you know, be less susceptible
to to to to sun damage.
So how is that not race based?
And it's a very weak argument.
But the question that you really have to kind
of ask is what political point is propped
up by arguing that it wasn't actually about
race?
Who does it benefit politically?
It benefits those who want to do nothing right
now about inequalities that exist along racial
lines to be able to say those inequalities
are not the result of any historical racial
oppression or discrimination.
As many people see, it absolves them of really
having to figure out or do anything about
the circumstances of racial inequality in
which the United States finds itself today,
which are, of course, much improved compared
to what they were.
They are not as bad as in many other countries
as I've said before, but they still exist.
And so that's the political point.
That's the reason why this is a narrative.
If you if you can even gaslight people into
thinking and the enslavement of African slaves
wasn't race based or racist, you can essentially
convince people of anything.
And that's exactly what they're trying to
do here.
We'll have more about this on our Instagram.
And I'd be curious to hear your thoughts about
it.
Instagram on Instagram, we are David Pakman
show all one word.
And if you want to see my eggplant on Instagram,
that's at David Pakman.
I've got two eggplants now growing in the
backyard.
It's really a sight to see.
Follow me there.
We'll take a quick break and be right back